I wake up between 6 and 6 30 to do Bible
study
um and see my husband off to work and
yeah you feed him
before he goes to work yeah oh no he
doesn't like eating okay he's not fast I
mean he might like grab cereal or
something but he's not really fast to be
honest and I don't make him pack lunch
he just he's not fast so I used to but
yeah but
um he yes I see my husband off and as of
six weeks ago my daughter decided she
wanted to go secondary school so now I
see her off to secondary school and my
husband takes her and then after I do my
Bible study a child will catch me go
upstairs brush their teeth and get them
fed and then
um we'll listen to some music and then
after some music and performance time
mommy watch me then we'll get into
homeschooling
so I homeschool three of the kids and
then my oldest one goes to how long does
that take you every day for the
homeschooling I'm just curious oh if
there is a rough on on average about
four hours four hours a day an average
year but then it just depends on the
kids sometimes they they're not with it
so
um yeah and then it comes to lunchtime
which is around the time where I make
lunch I make dinner and then I get the
kids to tidy up
and then we go out get the sister from
school then we come back sister does the
homework her homework then she tells me
her stories and like we have a little
bit of mom and daughter time kids are
playing and then we um tidy up again
before dad comes home depending on what
I look like I'll either like spruce up
or if I've got stains on my clothes I
quickly change just so like I look
presentable then oh thank You
Usher husband in then he comes and then
the kids do their whole dancing act Oh
Daddy watch me this is what I did today
and I leave them to it then he'll join
me in the kitchen while I prepare
everyone for dinner and that's when he
will ask me is do you need help with
anything and if I do I'll give you my
list if I don't then he'll go back to
the front room after our little chat
then we have dinner and then
um the kids before the kids go to bed
will
like do like a devotional together
um everyone prays to each other then the
kids go up to bed then my husband will
go up and pray for them and I sit down
and broke his necklace process then my
husband comes back down then we see it
we chill we watch a movie we laugh
whatever and then
if I'm being honest he'll probably go
out to bed first and then I sit down and
process and then force myself to go to
bed to when my body's exhausted and then
I go to bed and stuff may happen
at night stuff may not happen at night
then I do all over again and on the
weekend then the stepsons come over and
then there's football and then this
church and then this food bank
she's something do you have time to go
to the club in between I'm just curious
no but I didn't like honestly when me
and my husband want to get to liveo like
we just pick what the date nights are
gonna look like so it's like it could be
like a chilled one or it could be like
oh this are you saying you don't have
time to go to the club on the weekends
and do not have time to go to the club
oh no actually I do have a mommy's day
off let me not like every every day in
the week I do have a day off to myself
where I I run away and that's usually
the day that my husband works from home
so then he'll have the kids and he'll
work from home and I'm somewhere with a
girlfriend or something but then if that
can't work I will book an evening on a
weekend and I will go out with the girls
but yeah yeah foreign
[Laughter]
and what meals can you cook
English meals African Mills West India
Mills Indian Mills
yeah any well to be honest what if I
fancy it I'll learn it I'll learn to
cook it so I technically I can cook
anything
[Music]
but like in my locker I I can cook a
variety of milk and what what Lifestyle
Changes did you have to make from being
single to being married so they were in
the beginning there was two incomes
and I said to my husband I well I was
pregnant at the time I was like so my
husband said what's gonna happen with
the baby because I don't I didn't want
to do the nasty thing like because they
can't speak I don't know what's
happening
um and he was like well I'm not gonna
stop working and I said okay well you
can go part-time and I can go part-time
he was like no
so I didn't go back to work because I
want to be with my kids and he wouldn't
yield so I didn't have a choice it
wasn't me wouldn't you he wouldn't go he
wouldn't go part-time you really
expected him to say yes a little to be
honest when I first came into being a
wife it was a big shock to the system
because the things in my head was not
what it was in reality honestly I I
don't know a man I don't I I know what
I'd like a man to be like so I asked him
with I came boldly that's like
emasculated you work part-time I work
part-time on the same level not in my
head it's like yes yes we are on the
same yield and he was unyielding and
then I was with the dilemma I love him I
leave a goal and carry on working and
park my kids or I stay at home with my
kids and stayed at home with my kids and
it worked and what changes you have to
do from the two wages two incomes to one
so full transparency and I hope my
husband wouldn't mind but he makes the
money and he hands it all over to me so
I know what I'm working with and what I
want and what I don't want and I just I
work with what I have Jonathan she's
she's calling me ain't she you know
women work with what their husband
brings in that's basically isn't it
praise God my husband's like that
because I don't think I would be like
calm if I couldn't see money but like I
on his payday it's my payday because the
work drops in his account and
by midnight I'll see my bank account
fluctuate you mean you don't have to
begging about asking for money no
because I I I I divvy up the money so
he'll keep what he needs for him I was
just saying that because somebody said
that in traditional women when they
don't work in their housework that it
means that they're slaves and they have
to beg the husband for money no
no no
because I have all the money so if I and
my husband trusts me so if I if I want
to spend the money on a shopping spree
he knows everything else is covered how
did you how did you know you wouldn't
just be destitute
he could just leave you destitute high
and dry I mean to be honest he still
couldn't my mom has said to me now have
a private pot there that he doesn't know
about um
just in case he leaves you high and dry
kind of thing but like you can't get
nowhere you ain't going nowhere I'm
coming to him I mean I just I don't like
like you said about
um not holding on to negative thoughts
and stuff like that I mean what is the
point I'm living life for today so I'm
just gonna live chinch you know what I
mean do you feel like your marriage
could have still worked if you weren't
able willing to give up control no
because this is what I'm saying when I
got into my marriage I was very
controlling more controlling than I ever
could understand and I started to change
because he started to change because he
told me I I'm suffocating him that's
what he said to me and it made me feel
sad so like I had to work it out but my
excuse was my big crutch was well I've
been a single mom so I had to control
everything and I didn't have a man I'm
working out but actually I was
unyielding like I did not want to
like
I was not nice man did you have a couple
of counseling no we didn't he didn't
want to go
you just worked out how long did it take
you to have that switch would you say
she's still switching no no really I'm
still working I'm still working out but
I think I'm just not defensive anymore
so he could say like babe like kind of
thing and I'll be like oh okay sorry but
at the same time like he had some
passive Tendencies as well and I'll be
like babe like make a decision and he'll
be like listen I've got it I'll get back
to you whereas before it'll be like well
I don't know I don't know I don't know
so like we're still working out but as
the years go on like I say like this is
our eighth year into marriage it sounds
like you're going like that that you
these two were like that that was you
yeah that was him yeah and it was
somewhere yeah
I was somewhere where make it we've made
it to middle ground and now we're just
like maintaining it like sometimes I go
left sometimes he goes left but we know
where our Middle Ground is and like we
maintain it it it's it it's an ongoing
thing it's a journey it's not his
destination marriage is hard work though
you need to work at it that's what it is
yeah yeah and like commit so there's
times where my husband has not been
working there's times like when things
have been hard there's times when I have
not been touched by him like there's
we've had everything that you can think
of and then obviously because we're a
blended family you've got that them
difficulties to iron through but like
when I say that we're committed like we
are committed so I'm angry with you I do
not want to talk to you right now but
I'm not going anywhere yeah have you got
a big vehicle or you've got two vehicles
I've got a seventh CR okay then yeah I
was like where is she putting all these
kids in the end I would like a might
like another vehicle but yeah okay we
grew up with like a 16 passenger van who
was like yeah it's like one of those
things again I'll need a van for sure
yeah we have to let go of the cards yeah
yeah you guys don't really have them as
big as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible